[Musica]
benvenuto a Gerardo A dopo
l'adolescenza quel magico periodo in cui
i giorni ci sembrano tutti uguali perché
tutti i giorni Riceviamo sempre la
stessa domanda
Come è andata oggi a scuola
e Diamo sempre la stessa risposta bene
spesso però dietro quel bene Nascondiamo
un mondo di problemi
ricordo che quando ero a scuola mi
piaceva scrivere Dopotutto me stesso nei
temi di italiano ma prendevo sempre lo
stesso identico voto per la prof io ero
semplicemente un 6
prendere 6 per anni in ciò che mi
appassionava mi ha fatto sentire di non
essere abbastanza di essere un mediocre
come se un voto potesse Definire chi ero
e chi sarei potuto diventare e il
problema è proprio questo non sentirci
abbastanza nel tempo diventa
un'etichetta che ci mettiamo addosso
un'etichetta che influisce sulla scelta
dell'università del lavoro e anche delle
persone che pensiamo di meritare intorno
a noi
un'etichetta che ci spinge a ricercare
ancora di più
l'approvazione degli altri
a scuola ad esempio ci chiedono
continuamente quali università vuoi fare
e noi non lo sappiamo
sentiamo l'ansia di doverne scegliere
subito una per toglierci il problema e
anche se non ne troviamo una data a noi
ci adattiamo a scegliere la migliore
agli occhi degli altri
Dopo l'università siamo costretti a fare
un master perché l'università non basta
più per trovare lavoro e ci siamo Arresi
che sia normale così e poi un lavoro
anche qui quello che conta è che sia
importante agli occhi degli altri
avvocato medico ingegnere per poi però
arrivare a distanza di anni a chiederci
se fare 8 ore al giorno qualcosa che non
ci piace abbia senso se non ci siamo
persi qualcosa nella fretta di arrivare
a qualcosa che in realtà importante più
agli occhi degli altri che non a noi per
questo dobbiamo andare controcorrente
per riuscire a diventare noi stessi e
diventare noi stessi È proprio la
competenza più richiesta in un mondo che
non ha certezze
diventare noi stessi e probabilmente il
modo migliore per trovare il nostro
posto nel mondo per iniziare questo
viaggio la prima cosa che ci dobbiamo
che dobbiamo fare è toglierci le
etichette che ci siamo dati nel tempo
pensare non sono abbastanza bravo e
mollare ancor prima di averci davvero
provato e il più grande limite per
diventare noi stessi
dobbiamo essere capaci di toglierci
queste etichette come fossero dei
post-it e per riuscire a farlo
basterebbe essere più gentili con noi
stessi capire che ci possiamo perdonare
gli errori che possiamo imparare da loro
senza che definiscano chi siamo e chi
possiamo diventare
perché tra cinque anni non Ci
ricorderemo più quel voto basso quella
scelta sbagliata
Solo alla morte non c'è rimedio e una
volta che siamo più gentili con noi
stessi riusciremo anche a essere più
gentili con gli altri e a perdonarli
capiremo che non c'è un manuale di
istruzioni su come fare il professore su
come fare il genitore qualcuno
replicherà l'educazione che ha ricevuto
qualcun altro cercherà di andare
controcorrente per fare meglio
ok E una volta che ci siamo tolti le
etichette abbiamo iniziare a farci le
giuste domande
cosa mi piace fare
in cosa sono bravo per cosa mi possono
pagare come voglio dare il mio
contributo nel mondo
in Giappone rispondere a queste quattro
domande e unirle tra loro significa
trovare il proprio ikigai la ragione per
cui alzarsi ogni mattina
litigai non vedetelo come un punto di
arrivo ma più come una bussola per
trovare il nostro posto del mondo e non
è immutabile le risposte possono
cambiare nel tempo ed evolvere con noi
qual è però un problema
che per scoprire cosa ci piace fare
Dobbiamo anche fare attività che poi
scopriamo non piacerci che per scoprire
In cosa siamo bravi dobbiamo fare
attività anche in cui poi scopriamo non
essere bravi quindi dobbiamo accettare
che sbagliare strada faccia parte del
trovare la nostra strada
senza l'ansia di sentirci in ritardo
ogni volta che sbagliamo perché nel
viaggio per diventare noi stessi
non esiste la competizione e paragonarsi
agli altri e funzionare se ci ispira a
fare meglio non se ci fa sentire dei
falliti
e qui serve fare però una delle cose più
difficili in assoluto dobbiamo imparare
a deludere le aspettative di coloro che
amiamo
prima del mio lavoro attuale ho lavorato
per tre anni come consulente per diversi
parlamentari e in famiglia speravano
diventasse un parlamentare anche io come
succedeva diversi miei colleghi Eppure
sentivo che non era la mia strada
avevo però capito l'importanza di fare
politica e ognuno di noi fa politica
quasi ogni giorno quando sceglie Cosa
comprare quando scegli In che azienda
lavorare o quale azienda creare e io
volevo fare politica soprattutto facendo
impresa provando a dare quello che io
non avevo avuto a scuola all'università
la consapevolezza di dove stava andando
il mondo e gli strumenti per diventare i
protagonisti anziché semplici spettatori
Così inizia a pensare a un'idea folle
che non consiglio a nessuno
dare tutti i miei clienti ad altri
colleghi e investire tutti i miei
risparmi per fondare quella
quell'azienda che avevo in mente insieme
alla persona che amavo
in famiglia non tutti la presero bene
Qualcuno aveva molta paura per me
ricordo bene le sue parole Gherardo
Pensaci stai facendo un salto nel vuoto
da una parte hai la possibilità di
diventare un parlamentare
dall'altra non hai alcuna certezza
e non l'hai mai fatto
Pensaci bene perché per me è un errore
un grande errore
non fu facile ma alla fine Scelsi
comunque di fondare quella azienda
perché sentivo che era una scelta
coerente con chi volevo diventare
e arriviamo così ai compagni di viaggio
i nostri primi compagni sono i genitori
a volte abbiamo qualche conflitto ma in
realtà loro cercano di fare il meglio
per noi
e lo fanno in base alle loro conoscenze
la loro esperienza personale per questo
Noi dovremmo esserne grati senza però
dipendere dal loro supporto per essere
pronti a prendere la nostra strada Non
appena arriva il tempo di farlo
e vi ho detto dell'importanza di
deludere le aspettative degli altri
perché per anni ho fatto l'esatto
opposto Mi sono iscritto a
Giurisprudenza con l'idea di riuscire a
trovare poi un lavoro di successo agli
occhi dei miei genitori L'avvocato mi
laureai in tempo e Con un'ottima voto in
una prestigiosa università Ma quando
iniziai a cercare lavoro
ricevetti solo offerte non retribuite
con la classica frase inizia gratis e
poi si vedrà
scoprì quindi sulla mia pelle
che di avvocati non ce n'era bisogno
come vent'anni prima che l'avvocato non
era il lavoro prestigioso di una volta
cosa provai tristezza rabbia paura le
mie certezze erano a pezzi avevo già
fatto tre stage non retribuiti durante
l'università ed ero stanco di sentirmi
sfruttato
eppure quel fallimento è stato il dono
più grande che la vita mi ha dato perché
mi ha costretto a fermarmi e a
riflettere su dove stava andando non
potevo cambiare il mondo del lavoro ma
potevo cambiare le mie scelte È lì che
ho capito che la vita non è quello che
ci accade ma è come noi reagiamo a
quello che ci accade e quindi dissi di
no ad un lavoro non retribuito e mi
diedi il tempo di trovare la mia strada
che nel mio caso fu quella del digitale
digitale per me è stata l'opportunità di
trovare un lavoro ben retribuito perché
c'è molta richiesta da parte delle
aziende è stata l'opportunità di trovare
un lavoro
in grado di avere un impatto positivo
sulla vita delle persone e anche di
darmi un equilibrio vita lavoro che
sarebbe stato impensabile se avessi
fatto l'avvocato
ma soprattutto mi ha dato l'opportunità
di conoscere una delle persone più
importanti della mia vita
Virginia la persona con cui ho fondato
l'azienda di cui vi parlavo
e che qualche anno dopo mi ha detto sì
quando gli ho chiesto Mi vuoi sposare
per fare una prima scelta controcorrente
insieme vivere e fare impresa con la
persona che ami ma molto più
semplicemente la persona al mio fianco
in ogni momento importante della mia
vita Grazie di essere qui anche oggi
con Virginia ho imparato il significato
di amore incondizionato avere una
persona che cerca di supportarti a
trovare la tua felicità
a prescindere dall'approvazione degli
altri compresa la sua
ho imparato anche
L'importanza di avere qualcuno con cui
condividere il viaggio per andare nella
stessa direzione
consapevoli che insieme si può andare
più lontano e uscire più facilmente
dalla zona di comfort come quando al
nostro matrimonio mi ha fatto una serie
di scherzi è arrivata un'altra persona
all'altare in foto a sinistra potete
vedere sua cugina poi ha fatto arrivare
un amico comune che ha finto di opporsi
al matrimonio
non è stato facile perché ovviamente io
ero all'oscuro ma ormai con lei uscire
dalla zona di comfort è diventata quasi
la normalità non abbiate paura invece di
interrompere relazioni tossiche in cui
vi dicono magari sei cambiato e non ti
riconosco più Come se cambiare devo
evolvere costituisse di per sé un
problema come per il lavoro anche
Virginia è arrivata quando ho detto no a
ciò che mi faceva stare male quando ho
lasciato andare il vecchio per dare
spazio al nuovo
ed arriviamo così a un'altra importante
consapevolezza il viaggio conta più
della destinazione con Virginia
all'inizio siamo partiti con un tour di
orientamento gratuito nelle scuole sui
nuovi lavori più richiesti ma non è
andata Come speravamo i tempi non erano
maturi e ho imparato che ci vuole
pazienza che spesso non ce la facciamo
al primo tentativo e che va bene così
perché
sopravvalutiamo quello che siamo in
grado di fare in un anno e
sottovalutiamo quello che possiamo fare
in 10 anni
Non dobbiamo avere paura di quanto
grandi sono i nostri sogni c'è sempre
una strada per realizzarli la difficoltà
individuare i piccoli passi per
arrivarci
riuscire a goderci i piccoli risultati
che otteniamo giorno per giorno e
accettare i fallimenti che facciamo
lungo la strada come una parte
necessaria della nostra crescita
spesso diciamo non ho tempo Non so da
dove iniziare
quando in realtà non è mai un problema
di tempo ma è sempre una questione di
priorità e di scomporre obiettivi grandi
come ad esempio rispondere a tutte le
domande del litigai con
un obiettivo intermedio Come rispondere
ad una domanda soltanto per poi passare
alle altre
per me non è stato facile capire quale
obiettivo Volevo avere in particolare
non è stato facile capire quale
contributo volevo dare nel mondo mi è
servito tempo e alla fine ho capito che
potevo e volevo trasformare una grande
sofferenza in una missione a cui
dedicare la mia vita per anni mi sono
sentito io ho preso in giro da quelle
università che la giornata di
orientamento al liceo mi aveva promesso
tanti opportunità di lavoro per me con
un percorso di laurea che in realtà
sfornava disoccupati
mi sono sentito preso in giro perché mi
è sembrato che quell'università avesse
più a cuore che io pagassi la tassa
d'iscrizione rispetto a vedermi
realizzato mi sono sentito un numero non
una persona
per anni mi sono sentito in colpa nei
confronti dei miei genitori
per tutti i sacrifici economici che
avevano fatto per farmi studiare in una
delle università più costose in Italia
senza poi diventare avvocato
ma senza la sofferenza legata a quelle
emozioni negative non avrei mai avuto la
spinta ad immaginare un nuovo modo di
formarsi un nuovo modo di trovare lavoro
un nuovo modo di fare impresa senza
tutta questa sofferenza non avrei mai
creato Start Infatti University insieme
a Virginia
Grazie
ogni volta che sentiamo un'emozione
negativa come rabbia paura tristezza non
dovremmo reprimerla Dovremmo
innanzitutto ascoltarla a volte possiamo
trasformarla in energia per cogliere
problemi opportunità che gli altri non
vedono
siamo arrivati ai titoli di coda oggi
avete ascoltato tante cose qualcosa
magari vi è rimasto impresso più di
altro vi invito a fare un primo piccolo
passo per diventare voi stessi potete
stampare incorniciare litigai per
mettervelo in camera Oppure potete
scrivere una frase che vi ha colpito su
un post it e tenerlo sempre con voi
iniziate a circondarvi di domande e
pensieri in grado di aiutarvi a
diventare voi stessi per poi passare
alle azioni
riuscire a diventare voi stessi non è
una probabilità è una scelta che inizia
da piccoli passi non abbiate paura di
andare controcorrente non abbiate paura
di essere diversi perché dalla vostra
capacità di vedere la vostra diversità
come un valore dipende la vostra
capacità di essere felici e la vostra
felicità è una vostra responsabilità non
date a nessun altro questo potere perché
voi siete molto più di quello che oggi
Riuscite a vedere
dovete solo iniziare il viaggio per
scoprirlo e iniziare a mettere le vostre
speranze davanti alle vostre paure Vi
auguro di fare la differenza per voi e
per il mondo che volete creare non vi
prometto che sarà facile ma vi prometto
che ne varrà la pena perché il viaggio
per diventare noi stessi È il viaggio
più bello del mondo Grazie
[Musica]